let's give ourselves a little bit more
practice with logarithms so just as a
little bit of review let's evaluate log
base two of eight what does this
evaluate to well it's asking us or they
will evaluate to the power that I have
toward the exponent that I have to raise
our base two that I have to raise 2 to
to get to 8 so 2 to the first power is 2
to the second power is 4 2 to the third
power is 8 so this right over here is
going to be equal to 3 fair enough we
need examples like that in the last
video let's do something a little bit
more interesting what is what is an all
color-coded what is log base 8 what is
log base 8 of 2 now this is interesting
I'll give you a few seconds to think
about it well we're asking ourselves or
this will evaluate to the exponent that
I have to raise 8 to to get to 2 so
let's think about that in another way so
we could say 8 8 to some power to some
power and that exponent that I'm raising
8 to is essentially what this logarithm
would evaluate to 8 to some power is
going to be equal to 2 is going to be
equal to 2 well if 2 to the third power
is 8 8 to the 1/3 power is equal to 2 so
X is equal to 1/3 8 to the 1/3 power is
equal to 2 or you could say the cube
root of 8 is 2 so in this case X is 1/3
this logarithm right over here will
evaluate 2 will evaluate to 1/3
fascinating let's mix it up a little bit
more let's say we had the log base 2
instead of 8 let's put a let's put a 1/8
1/8 right over here so I'll give you a
few seconds to think about that well
it's asking us or this will evaluate to
the exponent that I have to raise 2 to
to get to 1/8 so if we said that this is
equal to X were essentially saying two
to the X power 2 to the X power is equal
to 1/8 is equal to 1/8 well we know 2 to
the 3rd power let me write this down
we already know that 2 to the third
power is equal to 8 if we want to get to
1/8 which is the reciprocal of 8 we just
have 2 raised to the negative 3 power 2
to the negative 3 power is 1 over 2 to
the third power which is the same thing
as 1 over 8 so if we're asking ourselves
what exponent do we have to raise 2 to
to get to 1/8 well we have to raise it
to the negative 3 power so X is equal to
negative 3 this logarithm evaluates to
negative 3
now let's really really mix it up what
would be the log what would be the log
base 8 base 8 of 1 1/2 what does this
evaluate to let me clean this up so that
we have some space to work with so as
always we're saying what power to have
to raise 8 to to get to 1/2 so let's
think about that a little bit we already
know that 8 to the 1/3 power is equal to
2 if we want the reciprocal of 2 right
over here we have to just raise 8 to the
negative 1/3 so let me write that down
8 to the negative 1/3 power is going to
be equal to 1 over 8 to the 1/3 power
and we already know the cube root of 8
or 8 to the 1/3 power is equal to 2 this
is equal to 1/2 so the lot log base 8 of
1/2 is equal to well what power after
raise 8 to to get to 1/2 is negative 1/3
it's called a negative 1/3 I hope you
enjoyed that as much as I did